we here at eight news now we are getting
into the holiday spirit and we're
teaming up with the good people over at
sunny 106.5
to help the other good people at
opportunity village an organization
that's been in the valley for such a
long time and as you see they're
joining us live this morning opportunity
village president and ceo
bob brown to talk about uh just how much
is uh
important for ov right now what's needed
during the holiday season bob it's good
to see you once again
great to see you john always great to
see you so thanks so much for having me
this morning you know it's uh this is
important work this fundraising where uh
you know everybody needs to remember
that opportunity village is owned by the
public we're nonprofits so
you know you own us and uh i think the
whole community can be proud of the way
we care for people
every single day and we've been doing
that since uh the kovic crisis started
and right now we're just fundraising to
try and save some jobs i mean
we really need to uh you know keep we
have to curate these people that we have
that care for others
and uh you know they're very difficult
to find and frankly
you know we don't want to lay them off
because we need them and so
uh as tough as it is we're muddling
through but uh i need everybody out
there to do what they can to try and uh
you know raise some money for
opportunity village and for people who
in
the valley who maybe don't know maybe
they're new here opportunity village
helps
adults with developmental disabilities
with employment with
advocacy with housing now betty's
village under construction
there's a lot of good work that gets
done at opportunity village
but because of the pandemic there's been
no magical forest a lot of the the
fundraising has been kind of ground to a
halt
what does opportunity village and what
do the the clients and the people that
what do they need right now
uh the most important thing obviously is
money uh i think
probably every non-profit in town needs
that so uh
what we're trying to do is we we're
staggering our shifts that we're not
keeping people
uh close to each other we've got a limit
from the state as to how many people we
can have
and that of course limits our funding
and so just trying to keep everybody
employed is the task at hand
and you know whatever you can do
fundraising is the key for us right now
how do you mention the challenges of a
non-profit right now
what kind of a razor thin edge right now
is opportunity village in terms of just
operations and and more and most
importantly helping the clients helping
the people with developmental
disabilities in the valley right now
so that they are not sort of left behind
well you know i'm really proud to say
that all the services that we provide
people
we're continuing those services so
people need our services
they're getting it and we've transferred
a lot of the work that we do
into in-home service uh so that we can
help people in their homes
uh but you know the need is great and uh
we're we're not backing down from any of
that
uh but the chap the challenge of course
is uh you know we've got some essential
contracts
that we do but we've got a lot of people
that have shut down
and so we don't have that work to do and
we pride ourselves in
going out there and you know having jobs
and making money
and bringing that back in so we can care
for others but uh because uh some of our
contracts have been cut it's been tough
john
it's it's it's really been a challenge
this and you're again you're gonna hear
that from every non-profit in town
and you know my my whole thing to
everybody is please
you know give one gift uh to another
non-profit just one
uh you know just maybe one less gift for
yourself and and pick your favorite
non-profit in town and give them a gift
because
i tell you they've never needed it more
than they need it right now yeah
and that need for for all the
non-profits including opportunity
villages
it's not going away certainly the
pandemic is still with us to be sure
so again we're talking about opportunity
village because of the
sunny christmas special that's coming up
this week and on uh and on christmas day
as well we've got las vegas headliners
taking part all to help
opportunity village there you see the
details there it'll be friday the
december 18th this week
we're hosting with the good folks at
sunny 106.5
all to help opportunity village bob it's
good to see you once again we're happy
to help and uh good luck to you and good
luck to the good people at opportunity
village
and we'll touch base with you later on
sarah thank you very much